e aí galera que assistir o canal tudo
bom vocês meu pai minha mãe quando se
casaram a intenção deles era um ter só
uma menininha só minha e pronto
só que aí vêm nem mais velho
depois vem o meu irmão mais novo quer
dizer o irmão mais novo o meu irmão mais
velho depois ver e eu e depois foi que
venha então o que acontece se tivesse
vindo irmã primeiro a deus todo mundo é
quando nasce como todo pai como toda mãe
estiveram dificuldade em colocar meu
nome e não saber qual nome escolher o
tantos nomes criativos e lindos por aí
eles ficaram com você sabe né aquela
aquela dúvida o nome de votar numa sofia
resto da vida
aí eu estiver a idéia é muito legal e
colocar o endereço on que lega né eu
nasci numa cidadezinha chamada pau pau o
qual que pau meia eu não sei como é que
se escreve e palmeiras o palmeiras faz
palmeiras corinthians vasco
a minha infância em palmeiras foi muito
boa porque ela tinha meu primo é
ecológico também para alegrar todo mundo
meu primo se chamava maydon e o povo
confunde a gente tem tinha cabelo enviar
no estilo tainá 2 em que era muito muito
amigo ética os melhores prêmios até é
encontrei ele estava brincando e que
resolveu pedir água nenhum comércio e aí
quando a mulher foi pega água e e em
shellman de bombom é ocorrendo de
peixoto
só que minha irmãzinha quando nasceu a
nossa comprova no coração
é a cirurgia era muito muito cara por
meus pais então não dava pra ouvir junto
com eles na hora surge então eu tive que
ir pra cima da linha chamada santa luz
que é onde minha avó mora foi foi um dos
piores períodos da minha vida
e mesmo que eu não sabia o que estava
acontecendo não sabe o que é a doença do
coração pra mim qualquer coisa febre ou
gripe é meu avô me deu um bezerro que me
alegrar e funcionou
tá parecendo um cachorro mas é visível
lá em santa luz eu conheci outro primo
meu que também era muito legal só que um
pouco de ódio dele porque tinha tudo
aquilo que eu não tinha sabe que o
nintendo e depois ele teve um play 1
depois de ter um play 2
eu até hoje tem um mega drive é isso que
todo mundo naquela época no interior
gostava de matar passarem a comer disse
ele que já tinha comida em casa e eu
peguei mata um passarinho dó e eu jurei
nunca mais motoca nenhum animal e depois
a minha irmãzinha voltou curada ea gente
foi morar em bom jesus que aqui do lado
dessas duas cidades
a partir daí gente foi só alegria eu eu
tenho orgulho de falar pra vocês que uma
das melhores infâncias da terra a gente
brincava de peteca sabe peteca de bater
pra cima e brincava e peão era muito
muito bom hoje descia nas ladeiras no
carrinho de rolimã acabavam concordou
braço do joelho mas não tinha coisa
melhor é muito bom e também foi a época
do meu primeiro amor e à época do meu
primeiro beijo meu primeiro beijo olha
que lindo sem sim eu tenho orgulho de
falar pra você tiver infância
maravilhosa primeiro que não tinha
sintomas de depressão tristeza deve ter
atenção não tinha tênis da hora boné de
marca um dia no ct tênis de luizinho que
era [ __ ]
não é querendo da omd nostálgico aqui no
meu tempo era bom aqui o meu tempo nem
sei o que não mas é porque eu vivi na
época em que o funk mais agressivo era
vou passar cerol na mão dança da morte
tinha só a cachorra era tudo assim ou na
primeira séria descobrir os melhores
amigos que eram walter e jorge é
raiva do val tem que saber ganhar o
quilo a segunda série era muito
estudioso na terceira série eu era muito
engraçado conhecido pelo seu lado
engraçado eu comecei a descobrir meu
lado engraçado na terceira série na
quarta para quinta série foi o meu
primeiro beijo no primeiro amor só que
no primeiro ano eu mudei de escola em
que fiquei longe todos os meus amigos
nessa escola tinha muitos laboratórios
de informática e gostava de assistir
vídeo no youtube foi a primeira vez que
eu assisti o vídeo do pc siqueira era um
veículo que falava na frente da câmera e
por algum motivo eu achei aquilo muito
muito legal a ponto de querer fazer
também o meu sonho desde pequeno sempre
foi pra televisão então houve no youtube
é tipo uma escada para poder chegar na
televisão
no início eu comecei fazendo com um
colega meu e não deu certo pois vai
fazer com outro colega mei quase não
certo aí depois eu fui fazer só e aí
fiquei com medo
a verdade é que eu tinha até um tanto de
visualização só com quase ninguém
gostava do que fazia ver eu era muito
tosco é muito muito ruim aí ô ô ô fim eu
fiquei puto fiquei com muita raiva muita
raiva eu fiquei porque eu conseguia
fazer as pessoas rirem fora do youtube
mas no youtube verão bosta
credo foi aí que eu parei de fazer vídeo
em 2011 eu voltei a fazer vídeos e eu
voltei muito melhor eu tinha até mais
visualizações mais pessoas gostaram
daquilo que eu fazia e foi que descobri
que o que faz você crescer é a qualidade
daquilo que você faz que eu voltei muito
bom mas gente assistiu então andava
quase todo dia 3 quilômetros foi na casa
da mariana debaixo do sol rachando é que
ela tinha uma câmera muito boa e eu
queria só mandar
imagem google para o youtube depois que
eu voltava na minha casa gravar o vídeo
editável tinha que volta a não é house
para poder enviar porque não tinha
internet a minha casa
nesse meio tempo eu conhecia o
ariosvaldo eu fiz a piada com o cabelo
dele
e me mandou tomar no cu ea gente viu
melhores amigos
um dia a gente ficou preso na escola ea
gente resolveu fazer um vídeo falando
sobre as dívidas do piauí deu até muitas
realizações nos meses depois eu viajei
quando eu voltei eu voltei criando a
paródia alô voto reprovado que estourou
no youtube conseguir 5 milhões de
visualizações
só que uma tarde boa tarde qualquer eu
comecei recebeu muitas mensagens
perguntando cadê o meu canal cadê o meu
canal quando o meu canal é eu fiquei
muito nervoso e foi o que tinha
acontecido
o que tinha acontecido meu canal tinha
sido excluído um rádio fã da [ __ ]
fiquei muito triste pensei em parar
porque tipo de demora muito tempo a
conseguir alguma coisa e não consegue
sair da vontade de parar eu comecei a
receber mensagens muito lindo sair gente
que adora meus vídeos e até piauiense
que morava em outro país daí foi aí que
eu fiquei maravilhado e resolvi voltar a
fazer vídeos
fiz outro canal no youtube começando do
zero
comecei do zero só que eu comecei a me
dedicar pra [ __ ] comecei a fazer
aqueles vídeos que eu achava que
realmente ia ser bom e aí foi que as
visualizações aumentaram mais ainda
claro nunca conseguiu 5 milhões de novo
mais tipo é muito e hoje eu faço vídeo
piau inteiro e até do brasil de aumentar
a pressão militar foi até chamado para
participar de um seriado daqui do piauí
chama que família é essa que vai ao ar
todas as terças às cinco horas da tarde
na meio-norte você não é do piauí tem no
youtube também eu conseguir todos os
meus inscritos de volta e ainda passei
deles se eu tivesse o meu canal antigo
teria 10 milhões de visualizações bom já
que só tem 18 anos e não tenho uma
história legal pra contar pra vocês vão
contar um pouco do que eu quero o meu
futuro o meu futuro eu quero uma família
legal sabe um mulher legal dois filhos
legais
o cachorro
uma casa legal é um cachorro não é eu
queria aproveitar esse vídeo para fazer
uma homenagem não pra mim mas sim pra
vocês que me apoiaram e nunca me
deixaram só porque vocês colocassem a
tag o inglês só 35 mil fãs no twitter
mas é mais uma forma de demonstrar
carinho
desculpa não tem uma história muito
legal pra contar pra vocês o exército
sou eu pra mostrar pra vocês vocês podem
dar a volta por cima em qualquer
tragédia que o testamento de vocês é
muito obrigado por você existir quem
fala que quem faz o artista são as
pessoas que vêem o trabalho dele porque
tem gente pra ver não tem artistas por
uma pessoa então muito obrigado a você
que não me deixou quando fui hackeado
muito obrigado a você que envia
sugestões muito obrigado a você que me
manda mensagens no facebook e no twitter
eu fico muito feliz com o carinho de
todos vocês eu sou enderson nunes
eu moro no piauí e faça vídeos pelo
youtube e prometo fazer vocês irem por
muito tempo obrigado
[Música]